welcome to this video yes a rapid game
yeah originally I planned to produce a
new the ewer game video but I did not
manage timewise but I can fill in this
this rapid game because I really wanted
to upload something in addition to them
to the daily Blitz videos so this
15-minute game is possible let's see
what happens yeah we get a king's indian
here hmm ok playing bondan bondan it's
got no name oh it's got a ton of games
played him quite an experience account
that same ok so I I yours for c5 so we M
won't get a typical Kings Indian
structure with e 5 in fact the region's
pose to the maroc see bind which is
normally arising either from the
Sicilian it is some belonging to a
Sicilian traditionally but quite often
comes from 1c for one night f3 in this
case it comes from a king's indian you
have many roads lead to Rome in this
case to a typical maroc see bind
precision position yeah black yeah
Bishop d7 or takes on d4 animals in that
case I'd like to play right to see to an
old favorite of mine it looks a bit
strange to voluntarily withdraw this
might from the center but White's idea
is that in general um he has more space
like a slacking space here he is
confined to this three ranks and yeah
quite often
it is a good idea to keep as many pieces
on the board as possible in this kind of
scenario this is why I did not want to
trade the knight on d4 and withdrew it
voluntarily ok rukia's is kind of a yeah
almost like a nothing move that it's not
doing very much sometimes black is a bit
afraid that Queen a5 is going to be
answered by 95 with a discovery so that
it covers e7 but I'm not sure that this
is important here rugby one is a good
versatile move it removes the rook from
the long diagonal and also prepares move
like before sometimes in the answer to
Queen a five if I play before now he
might have Knight to e5 though this
looks a bit uncomfortable stood before
as a good move in case he goes Knight c5
interesting yeah what is it that I can
do I can play a move like 95 for example
that wouldn't be bad to centralizing
that is also reason why rook be one is
off useful that covers to be to pawn now
let's see what he's doing sometimes they
go for f5 in this type of position just
to kind of the kind of I want I would
move f5 yeah maybe it doesn't really fit
with rook e8 though one constant problem
let's say her black is that this night
will put on to be put on d5 invariably
and well then you sit there's black and
kind of think okay I cannot tolerate
this piece but if you take it yeah like
in this case he gives up the bishop pair
um and yeah it's not not really am that
welcome to give that up what am i doing
now actually both recaptures are quite
good even see txt 5 which is not so
typical is some quite interesting here
Keeks 95 yeah his lights are standing on
each other's toes I don't think I can
take a seven this is going to be
answered with b6 so let's say cd59 to e5
Bishop e7 he's got b6 and he were
trapped the bishop this looks some kind
of ugly I cannot ever place he takes 95
and then any move let's say not taking
on SL typically however eat XD 5 is
there is even the better better choice
I'm going to do that long-term this
intends to put some pressure on the
e-file which is really long term here
because I have the e-file completely
crowded with bishops and not so easy to
entangle one problem where they said his
knights a little bit yeah this is all a
little bit misplaced f1 now is the
threat I played b3 to cover the sea for
porn so this is a very stable structure
now a typical pawn chain a2 b3 c-45
that's very neat and well the simple
idea is f4 and the night is history now
let's see what is doing sometimes you
can play the F pawn to give the night
the f7 square but in this particular
case there is no light squared Bishop
anymore so f 594 looks really ugly and
while ugly is really bad let's say it
looks bad so what is he doing yeah
something like this this does make quite
some sense ok that play F for now he
gets the e4 square which is not very
helpful
so let's see what are we going to do now
to divorce simply centralizing this this
cannot be bad so let's not invest tons
of time black is confined to very little
here one possible counter plays a 6b
five trying to attack my chain here but
I'm on b5 with the bishop the pawn and
the night that's very difficult to play
yeah it seems like he tries anyway but
tricky um one idea now is also be 4i can
I could just play for that be4 c5 now
before yeah that's not bad at all if I
go F 497 I really give up the foursquare
I don't don't like that very much but
okay I'm in a situation here absolutely
he can they cannot do much in terms of
activity let's think about this what do
I want to do it's a very comfortable
situation yeah it's a situation where he
has no poem break b5 is bad e 6 opens up
the position for my bishops f5 is
dreadful so he's confined to shuffling
pieces around he doesn't have any any
positive plan let's say well I can try
to push the queenside yeah I think I'm
going for that yeah let's prepare this
be four c-54 system the main plan I have
some ways to prepare this this business
I don't need to do this right away moves
like let's say Bishop f1 Bishop f2
securing everything a little bit is that
they are possible and we should never
forget that in the meantime he has to
play some moves and sometimes in a
situation where there's nothing active
to do the defending side here black
um yeah tends to do something to worsen
the pollution move like f5 let's say or
ecigs it's difficult to just stay put on
what you can try in order to slow down
my quince i play something like a six to
a five but this gives away b5 forever so
hmm it's not a happy movie yeah as I
said it might happen that it tries to
free himself with some some violent
action like this okay so let's have a
look here that's an interesting
situation because we definitely can try
to punish him for that very very
directly let's say I go b4 b4 in case of
Knight to d7 I can play F for aunt is
son 'if I've neither strapped so after
before yes to go to a form after which
let's say f 497 d is six every six
Bishop g4 is a possibility now that
sense that's definitely definitely quite
good if I take on e6 right away he can
take with the night like Teague's night
x 19 26 roop check c6 yeah it's also
kind of ok ok I'm going to start with
that movie no biggie wasn't pretending I
would actually play something else so
before I yes to go to a 492 d7 f4 is
just wrapping the five night in the
middle of the board it has absolutely no
square so he has to go to a forum
there's no big choice here
unless I'm overlooking overlooking some
some tactic some tactical defense
I don't really think so maybe you can
think about each XD 5 like eat XD 5pc 5
DC 5 and my night is attacked and after
it moves like d4 that's very hard to
believe let's have a look though at
night to a forum is there maybe even
something better than just the F form
and capture business f 497 that there's
no direct window a I mean it's not like
I'm winning immediately f4 Knight to d7
hmm defea Bishop g4 Bishop g4 night f8
or something like that it's not
brilliant for black but I wonder if it's
the best turn best continuation I can
also start with the capture only six not
sure ever there's any any difference
they are this F for Bishop g4 business
it has one added weakens a little bit
it has some yeah it just weaken a little
bit i'm not totally sold on the idea
especially for is weakened by this F 497
div Bishop chief form hmm and then we
can exceed four in case he returns
tonight to be six there yeah yeah I am
that isn't that isn't so clear at all
might be it might be good for me but
it's not like completely a completely
simple or in any way on a super big
advantage something like that ok I'm
going to start with that it is it should
be it should be still right however
after his retreat he has to go to the
seven i believe and let's say some
tactica i'm a bit vulnerable here on the
e-file but i don't think there's
something happening a 97 looks like the
only move my idea was then to take is
six and play Bishop to f3 not go to g
form and maybe i can go to g4 bishop
earn night f8 but it doesn't have to
play neither medic can also play Queen
f6 almost like that so 97 d6f e6 bishop
f3 maybe direct them this is a bit
better taking b7
maybe you can still play not to be 6mm
now interesting blacks position is so
pretty pretty sturdy I'm a bit irritated
the hole that is taking time here why
why not just 97 what am i overlooking
overlooking something like after 97 have
a simple win or something like that I
don't think so hmm kind of curious why
is he thinking for so long
after Knight to d7 I mean what I can
always do is I can insert this Quincy
tune with or queen d one simply am
attacking the a4 night but you can go
back to be six I don't really see a huge
problem there yeah so we finally played
this move huh am i overlooking something
I'm really am really a bit mystified by
the wrong thing but I don't see a see
something great okay let's take them and
play Bishop e3 simply claiming that I'm
better with the bishops which is not not
an entirely outlandish assumption
bishops look good there yeah that move
but I thought bishop t5 chicken 96 would
be quite good let's check let's not
waste any time now and go go in to e6 I
will either get the bishop or an
exchange
the other g7 Bishop is an important
defender of his skin position sorry for
that sound and you too I spilled some of
my drink on the desk yeah so 196 yeah
should he give the exchange there I
don't really think he has got any
compensation if you place rupee 6
relatively speaking yes the relatively
best seems to be a queen move but it
doesn't look good I can also take be
seven at the end of that I'm just seeing
that now it looks dreadful really yeah
is there something better than just
taking them fe5 for example every hive
Queen e5 I play Bishop before and win
the house tonight tieks I can play
Bishop g4 anything I like yeah come on
that useless I'm just taking the bishop
p.m. let's not be too sophisticated
I still be seven hanging simply so let's
see do I just take a b7 here on what is
best I'll take them it is simple but
also quite convincing it's a pawn and
I'm taking a six so it's an optimist one
part if he moves the rook to be your
default i also have Bishop to see 60 I
was thinking Bishop before him
hmm Bishop d4 will win they exchange p
should be 495 bishop CA Troxy aid and
c-5m there is no count to play really
yeah let's do that let's take the
exchange Bishop f4 wasn't wasn't bad
either and c5 I think this is an
important new hire after i saw that i
have this move i decided to take the
exchange because this is some this is
making sure that the night only five
loses its support pawn on d6 which means
that this pin on this diagonal after on
the queen and king would be very very
problematic also note that the night on
a4 is absolutely no square so that is
not looking good yeah yeah think this is
pretty much resigned abble i might be
just read threatening am now queen seat
we might have Knight f3
yeah okay it's kind of last hope move
yeah if he takes on g2 he has the night
f3 this this thread so let's see um I
just a cheek on d6 I have a ton of
threats on my own actually Roxy one
would see one threatening rook c7 also
yes he really has no dangerous counter
take mostly because of me needs
materially down anyway and the night on
a4 is totally out of play so he's hoping
for this Knight f3 check um yeah but i
was thinking i can just take a five
actually bishop jakes b 5 he doesn't
even have a check at least i don't see
one Luke see one check rook see one jack
yeah Queenie 5 and in this position
after Queen takes d5 and he does not
even have a check not a single one which
means I have one moment here to improve
my position let's see also trading
Queens would be would be need um do I
get this n I can't go give this check
their on c7 King g8
it's no direct win I can use this
happened oh yeah that's definitely
possible but still do I don't have a win
97 checking g8 I really have no checks
now I mean I can now have this is not
even helping okay so let's push the pawn
black resigns I was just thinking if I
haven't made or something there should i
should play that but there wasn't yeah
this is a reality typical game from the
maracas see bind in a in a scenario
where black is suffering a bit of space
there I think after it goes after here
at he takes d5 this is a very serious
concession um maybe he has to stay I to
be honest I don't like blacks position
here anyway because of the big space um
I actually prefer it very much if at all
if I'm at all in this is black to trade
on deform earlier and make sure that
this is a he plays out those moves um
yeah and here the the bigs the big space
advantage is really a really a problem
black as i already said during the the
live commentary black is lacking in Palm
brakes and his playing one this is six
porn break but it only leads to yeah an
opening of the position ya hear the
computer gives this move as I already
mentioned during the the live commentary
I did not really believe in it but maybe
this isn't hacked an option something
like this looks at least kind of kind of
tricky
yeah sorry guys I have to unpause in
this for a moment yeah back I I just
started a new examination bought that I
can examine on my own on and always a
slightly irritating thing if they put
out moose um I really would advise black
players too oops to play this move order
making sure that one pair of minor
pieces is traded with the little space
this is a much more convenient way to
play it some this kind of thing here so
there are various little move order
things but this kind of position it is
really helpful here for black that one
pair of minor pieces is traded makes it
the defense much easier here on i mean
it's not like black is lost or anything
but it is more difficult to play as some
the set of minor pieces that is kind of
all those pieces yeah they compete for a
limited number of squares and they're
kind of stepping on each other's toes I
think start yes is totally normal yeah
and starting from here I think he
absolutely should not take I mean I i
don't know i mean f5 looks really really
weakening and kind of not near not well
in sync with rookie aid but maybe still
at least my rogue wolf is also not
perfect him now that is slightly better
for why this position but it's nothing
nothing super super special yeah maybe
you should still play a five I think
after that I'm definitely better and I
am better with both continuations both
eat XD 5 octa xt5
in fact I often take with the sea pawn
in these positions but this time I
wanted to play it differently like here
here and then b3 is some a good way to
play covering the c-4 square so that f4
is now a threat winning a piece black
has to play something like that and
again we have a situation we have his
lacking space White has two bishops and
they both point towards the queenside
very nice i just struck see one for
example and and white is just better
it's um it's a simple fact here than two
bishops like has no compensation for
that and the space it's also good this
is also good it's a matter of matter of
taste see 594 I I'm pretty okay with
with all that um it's interesting I'm
not not totally sure about all those
moves if you want drug see one or not in
the scenario why I play f4 and Bishop f3
there might be might be debatable if you
maybe want the looks on d1 any Vanya now
like here and here that can also be an
idea but I was thinking that be4 c5 is
my general plan especially if he is just
doing nothing which I kind of expected
but ok 26 jam if you can really argue
about before now if he takes d5 is a
move amazing I mean okay what I
mentioned already in the live commentary
I can take Knight takes Knight takes
rook takes and this is still definitely
a bit better for wide still two bishops
d5 is weak d6 this week yeah it's a it's
a bit better for wine but I wanted to
scenario where he has to take with the
pawn but okay if this is really a move
and it might be when the b4 move might
be dubious I had this hunch but I
couldn't really believe in it and the
computer just once to recapture on d5
well
is not what I want because this is a
very Undine amick pawn structure which
is not so favorable for the bishops I'm
still liking Wyatt but it's not what I
wanted let's check though if I check
here d Teague's yeah no no I have to do
that it takes this is the computer line
hmm I it's all based on neat neat
tactics mmm very nice if it if this
wasn't wasn't working yeah if if if but
it does work if I check here it's a huge
mistake check so I actually have to go
back c4 night a5 and something like that
or no yeah this is this is a very tricky
he's got strong advanced pawns and my
night only five is not the best piece
ever interesting computer judges this is
equal ok so maybe before wasn't super
precise Lenya i guess i guess i have to
do this then right ninety four hmm yeah
again I rather be white but that it
stopped it's not easy at all not a clear
advantage it's just a little bit a
little bit more comfortable ok he went
to there and now I went for this space
gainer the computer again wants to take
on d5 interesting
yeah okay well this is interesting Black
has two pawns and it's active so not a
not a bad idea it's not enough
objectively probably but it's better
than just suffering which is kind of
happening here yeah okay I went here
immediately my first idea was this and
but I wasn't sure here this is of course
a very sensible alternative first trying
to push this night bag and then put it
on f3 but Bishop f3 is good it just has
this very simple idea and black yeah
black doesn't have a super great answer
to that rooks e7 maybe after that the
computer wants to play Bishop g4 might
indicate that Bishop g4 earlier was even
stronger but okay this is some we don't
need to be very deep here with the lines
this is an open position again with
those two pieces here the night on a
force offside I have the better
structure to islands against three it
must be better for wine comp is on 1.2
so it's it's quite quite a bit after a
five it is I think just losing check and
96 yeah let's plus for take just
grabbing stuff and see if I or queen d 1
is also quite stronger okay let's see
five is good it's um destabilizing this
night and after see takes
chicks check where t7 this is even
though it even needs to a mate and the
comp season made in a couple of moves
yeah ok I get the new queen and as
mentioned he does not even have a check
even with preparation it's hard to give
one so there is no hinder from counter
plane yeah the maroc see bind um which
which normally arises from from this
order yeah road to the hopes to the game
position is this lets them exactly the
same position or a different route is
something like this out of the English
opening where we get to this also quite
logically this kind of position is
something that a white player plays
Knight f3 or C for those kind of
openings them should know how to play
and for white if you play 1.e4 and you
face the accelerated dragon it is
something that really should be
considered even if you're normally favor
let's say please play and attacking play
with in style of the Yugoslavia check
yeah with Bishop c4 long canceling yeah
even then even if you do prefer that
studying the maracas see we'll see form
it's very rewarding it's a little bit
it's a very comfortable opening for wide
and yeah i'm a bit biased because I have
such a huge score with it but still it
is a good opening it gives white
constantly good results and is normally
leading to positions where you have very
very good control wouldn't little
counter play to fear yeah I hope you
enjoyed this game thanks for watching